Gregory is my name John is what they
call me
intro complete Batman The Killing Joke
so John he went to go see at a theater
yesterday I went to go see a theater
yesterday one night special event for
Batman The Killing Joke it was an
interesting experience because prior to
the movie starting there was there's an
interview of Mark Hamill explaining the
whole history and his dedication and why
he chose after announcing on Twitter
Arkham Knight the videogame was his
final Joker performance that he had to
come back for The Killing Joke it was
motivating it was inspiring
I had there's so much enthusiasm and
then the movie started it gets you
pretty pumped up yeah and you feel like
in an isolated know you feel the
greatness of Mark Hamill you're like wow
he really is great yeah he really is
dedicated to this role like it's more
than just an actor doing a voiceover
like he really does like know the
character and the movie starts and then
the first like 2025 minutes is a bad
girl story see I I was tired so it felt
like a long time like no it was that was
it really only 20 okay
this is gonna be a spoiler review cuz
you know like I'm betting you a lot of
you like watching this review that
probably reread the comic does this all
40 minutes it's like a direct adaptation
of The Killing Joke which is really cool
in its own way but the thing is though
is like that would have been cool if the
first 20 minutes was in there not
because like I was in the audience late
first time you've been at die the
resident sucks it just [ __ ] up the
whole tone and the whole pacing it feels
on even like it [ __ ] up the whole
experience like literally if I were to
go back and re-watch this I would
probably just skip to the gym yeah where
the where the book begins cuz I bet this
film would be much better this Batgirl
story um I have so many problems so that
one it's poorly written it's very poor
like the way they characterized her at
all like the decisions she was making
she didn't seem like you know a woman
who would be out in the city capable of
fight it like she seemed like that
like our like a Batgirl character on
like a CW animated show at two o'clock
in the afternoon I couldn't get the
sense for who she was really I was like
if she's supposed to be really younger
she's supposed to be like an adult
Batgirl I thought she was annoyingly
written I hated that they had this whole
it's not just a quick little story about
Batgirl it's like if there's this whole
mob story about this specific mobster
it's long enough that I thought back and
went I don't remember this keeps going
and you're just like I came here to
watch like a joker movie what is all
this stuff
there's nothing to do really with the
rest of the film it kept making me
wonder if I if I miss stuff and it's
long enough to the point where it's not
just a prologue they tacked on like it's
an active movie I don't like the Batman
and Batgirl dynamics in it at first
there was like this one little touch I
was like that not cute Batman like
answer like a cup of coffee after she's
had a rest really stressed out day yeah
kind of funny okay had a relation it's
just so beyond like everyone in the
theater Edward I kid you not
every soul in this back meter just
started going to whoa what the [ __ ] is
going on right now yeah and that's the
thing is like I don't think that
couldn't ever work but the way they play
it does it for a minute I was like this
could be interested oh it seems out of
character and witness specially made it
out of both of them what if I specially
made it out of character was after they
[ __ ] and then the next day when
they're not talking for a few days and
then there's like this moment really get
on the phone hey am i getting invited
hey um later like hey the way they talk
to each other's like are you guys in
[ __ ] high school it's a melodrama
it's like a melodramatic scene with with
Batman window-dressing it's at it ruins
Batman's image it ruins the image of the
bat for this particular tale yeah so
many reasons and to put it on the front
of this like it dilutes you know it's
these weird little notes that dilute the
character because they later on he when
the movie plays it as The Killing Joke
he becomes basically like Batman it just
sets this is a weird foundation for in
this particular story in this particular
this specific story there's a moment
where Barbara talked and this in the
comic where Barbara talks to Gore
and gordon's like hey this is the first
time when Batman and Joker met and
Barbara's like I was just a kid then
establishing that when Batman was around
she was just a little girl that's has
been working with Commissioner Gordon
then he takes on his his daughter to be
Batgirl which is already gonna piss off
Commissioner Gordon well and any boxer
this is a father to Batgirl
this could have all been interesting in
a different movie that was only about
this with much better characterization
but as it is here it's just like a big
salad bowl full of beer oh is this 20
minute movie that tried telling this
other mops or this villain that just
sucked like that villain of the mob
family he just sucked yeah I was like
why would she get really into this game
and like take it so personally like if
she's really the Batman's mission and
stuff like insisted make any sense to me
then made that character kind of dumb
that girl came off as kind of a dumb
character came up as a dumb character
it's kind of an it's an and here's the
worst part the worst part about it none
of it matters for the rest o none of it
adds more effect see I read The Killing
Joke twice in my life I read her like a
week ago and I read it like many years
the rest of it very accurate in a comic
which is cool but the lead-up of the
tone that the movie sets you in and the
mood that it sets you in it isn't it
doesn't allow you to properly experience
the actual Killing Joke story because
the 20 minute because you spent yeah
like 20 minutes on this others story
that seems like it's only purpose is to
make the moment where Barbara gets shot
more impactful and I like we don't need
it to be another story is lopsided cuz
like it makes Commissioner Gordon feel
like a tacked on character you know yeah
and it just and like it shows no further
effect on Bruce Wayne you know the
effect on Batman well it kind of makes
the ending work less it wakes the ending
words less when Batman goes to visit her
in the hospital he finds out okay like
okay she's paralyzed and he just finds
out from the cop that she was probably
raped and no sense of the fact that they
but had feelings for each other that
they just [ __ ] one week prior to this
incident yeah it's like if you're gonna
make all those choices you got to make
them effective yeah proper way later so
it makes the whole movie feel very on
now the storytelling points are just
like all off B it doesn't feel like what
was happening so far is you know like it
doesn't feel like the plot that led to
this yeah and it's like if you're gonna
take that much creative freedom in your
first 20 minutes of the film you've got
to take some creative freedoms
throughout the rest of Li yeah and this
is like a classic Batman story people
love it it's Alan Moore this is the time
to attack something on and [ __ ] around
if you're not really gonna nail it if
you're gonna rewrite the whole first 20
minutes gonna add this whole thing in
there try to match Alan Moore's writing
you have to have some creative freedom
to make the whole thing flesh out more
it and move smoother than out instead of
just alright now from here on out direct
adaptation of the comic it just makes it
feel it's like do this you're making a
movie right now
I get that you're like trying to satisfy
fans and whatever but your first 20
minutes was a half-ass r-rated attempt
and now the rest of the film is harder
to appreciate that frustrated me too cuz
everyone made a big deal about like oh
it's their first like r-rated animated
movie and it felt more tame than a lot
of their other animated movies and
especially when they step into our rated
material one that I wanted them to draw
more but like the sex scene is literally
a pan up and that's not an r-rated sex
scene like anytime someone is about to
swear anything that's worse than like
dammit or [ __ ] like yeah they
immediately say something else that's
clean that feels really shoved in like
all the r-rated elements feel like they
really were timid about them which is a
bummer cause like it's a gritty story
sinister story what I will say is that
okay if for a fan for a fan of The
Killing Joke as myself and firstly I
know The Killing Joke apart is like the
music is really cool I've seen a lot of
these Lisi animated films ever since
like mask of the phantasm been watching
these it's very sinister it's very
creepy it hits all these tongues right
that make it a very unnerving experience
yeah the problem is whenever the film is
not in that really dark creepy territory
the other stuff comes across as cheesy
that's my biggest they didn't have as
good of a grip on just the talking tone
it had to yeah like the tone was really
cool in the action scenes are in the
scary sort of macabre carnival stuff or
the flashbacks I thought were cool yeah
like out of all the actors who have done
the Joker
camel is the perfect he's asked one he's
to record The Killing Joke adaptation
horrific and he even gets a musical
number like Mark Hamill like really is
great like yes his deliveries great
throughout he brings a lot like they
show him in that BTS stuff like he's
moving around you can feel it it's like
it's a very lively performance I think
he's terrific and and that that musical
part is really cool because in the book
he does that is the musical number but
yeah there's no music when you in the
book so the fact that he's brought it to
life was like hey Mubarak live in it and
made it like really creepy especially
towards the end cuz if the music's going
over when Gordon's going through the
weird fun maze horror maze whatever that
[ __ ] is that he's going through well and
I thought Gordon was good too I like
very wise but by the ending of the film
like and there's a lot of different
interpretations as to why Batman starts
laughing along with the Joker it's this
particular telling it does not work and
it makes Batman look bad because he
doesn't put Batman on a character growth
at all with any of you prior effects it
just makes him seem crazier and and less
absorbed all that extra stuff
I mean you pointed this out to me
earlier it's like with all that extra
stuff we saw the beginning with Barbara
the whole thing that the Joker you know
like sets into place with Barbara and
Jim like it just seems like he would
never like he would be even more pissed
now cuz it's not about their
relationship it's about you know his
friends no yeah like the Joker
[ __ ] try killing this woman that he
just [ __ ] that he kind of raised for a
while I was like inside and then
Commissioner Gordon who's is like his
number one go-to human buddy outside of
the bat family so it doesn't seem like
it's a Batman and the Joker which is
part of what yes that and that's what
makes the whole thing on me because like
first 20 minutes is about Batgirl then
we got Batman sort then Joker and
Commissioner Gordon that grab a girl and
a battle who I thought that they were
gonna twist into being the guy who would
eventually become Joker I know they had
to pad this movie because it's only like
80 82 minutes or something like that so
The Killing Joke must not have been long
enough The Killing Joke parts I really I
liked I enjoyed a lot so it's not like
you're gonna hate it so yeah like the
voice acting is great I mean even though
there are times where like the animation
seems more animated and like
there should be more expressive in their
voice I really I feel like the voice
direction not the app not the voice
actors because we know Kevin Connor and
Mark Hamill can [ __ ] kill it every
single time and they do but the
animation sometimes it's not matched
with the level of their voice yeah yeah
and I mean it kind of bothers me I wish
that they would commit to hand animation
if they want it to look like that
because there are a lot of things that
they do now when they put in something
that's clearly computer anime like the
merry-go-round it's like clearly a
different kind of animation it just
takes you out of the beauty of the art
form and there's some times where
characters move jerky or the mouths
don't really matter yeah it's an uneven
experience and what if nothing else was
wrong I wouldn't care so much but while
there's periodically moments of
greatness there's a lot though that
really did bother me by the time the
movie was done when you got a jam-packed
house full of excited people ready to
watch The Killing Joke these are
hardcore DC animated fans and then no
one [ __ ] collapse by the time this
becomes tonight is pretty bad sign like
it was still cool like there's still
stuff like the stuff that's cool and and
magical like you still enjoy I feel like
everybody left the theater felt like
something was it's uneven and the ending
makes it even more confusing because the
first 20 minutes Batman's just an
emotionally abusive controlling [ __ ]
[ __ ] this young girl it's a Zen ignores
her and then he makes the end all about
fit you know I don't want to kill you
I'm a better person kidneys Allan more
stories are very difficult to adapt into
meets because they're not the basis for
a lot of Hollywood movies you know like
his movie his stories are not jammed
have you imagine challenging there's
usually a heavy on dialogue heavy on
philosophy talks and those are not
exactly the comic-book action sequence
material that we usually expect and yeah
it's like this movie I've seen a lot of
DC animated films on because this is The
Killing Joke there's really primarily
dialogue in this film not not that many
action sequences yeah and that's what
the the extra 20 minutes also held so
it's like there are several fights
totally fit with the rest of the film
that's a weird choice Matt like I
thought like it's cooling concept like
it could have worked just in a different
movie like a five minute recap of who
the [ __ ] back girl is and then move on
have a backstory that links to the
actual we really take your time doing
The Killing Joke cuz it's not a very
thick graphic novel no you know so I
understand that they might need to
expand it but this wasn't the way to do
that I felt like they were afraid to
like put in additions throughout the
story yes then they just threw in some
creative thing and to fill out the time
instead of going for new - very faithful
just you know yeah faithful and take a
few liberties here and there and
intersperse them throughout and use them
to augment the story that you do have
because it is a rich Batman and Joker
story that feels less rich or movie like
this well guys I think this film two out
of five batarangs and I give it to
I'll give it two and a half out of five
Red Hood one out of five Barbara Gordon
oh no we're not rating that way that's
horrible
I'm sorry it's okay you should be
ashamed of yourselves bad but the real
ready go yeah shawne's Jerry
facebook.com slash blue house find out
what that's all about
I want to give a shout out to a guy
named Aaron he was sitting right next to
us in the theaters he didn't tell me
that he knew who I was until the movie
was done he wanted to watch him yet you
want to watch my reaction we want sure I
thought he's gonna verify your feelings
and I let him know right away like what
the fight actually Aaron when that when
that girl in Batman like it started
hooking up I just like leaned forward
and I looked over I saw this dude who I
hadn't seen the whole movie and he we
just looked at each other like what the
[ __ ] is going on anyway good luck but
you're next DC animated film yeah